depuis janvier de nouveaux véhicules ont
fait leur apparition dans la plaine de
versailles
un mode de transport d'un nouveau genre
un service de bus à la demande certains
le test pour la première fois une tc ce
matin à 9h30
j'avais pris l'application il ya une
semaine comme ça je vais déjeuner sur
paris donc les tester c'est assez
pratique
mocky et se remarient son mode en
général j'ai ma voiture là je prends pas
la voiture et j'ai voulu tester je pense
que lexie go c'est vrai que c'est simple
flic sigaud emmène les voyageurs de la
communauté de communes de gally mauldre
vers les gares ou les autres arrêts du
territoire pour réserver son trajet site
internet applications mobiles ou par
téléphone
un dispositif qui répond à un véritable
besoin pour cette zone rurale déjà 370
voyage ont été réalisés la première
préoccupation là le premier soit la
première demande des habitants et des
usagers c'est effectivement d'avoir des
moyens de transport qu'ils soient
meilleurs que ce qui existait c'est
grâce effectivement aussi à
ile-de-france mobilité qui est le
nouveau nom du stif et a donc à la
région ile-de-france qui maintenant
véritablement est de la grande couronne
la région qui finance aux deux tiers ce
nouveau dispositif le premier en ile de
france
au total environ un million d'euros par
an sont investis pour cette expérience
un concept qui pourrait arriver dans
d'autres territoires